the last moments of jalen walker's life
are disturbing to watch
police and walker's family all agree he
was unarmed when eight police officers
fired
as many as 90 times leaving 60 bullet
wounds and killing him almost instantly
at the time of the shooting he was
unarmed
from there the stories diverge releasing
the video and outlining the apparent
facts of an ongoing investigation handed
over to state police akron's police
chief said 25 year old jalen walker
drove away from a routine traffic stop
over a moving violation in a broken
taillight
as walker left the still-rolling car in
a ski mask a gun magazine and a ring
possibly a memento from walker's fiance
who died a month earlier were left on
the seat the two sides appear even to
disagree on whether so many shots were
too many videos that they did not show
us
is a video of him actually getting out
of the car jalen actually getting out of
the car and you can see his hands
does that strike you as excessive i'm
not passing judgment on the decisions my
in my officers made
they will be given the opportunity to
explain
why they did what they did as they
should with the amount of shots that
were fired that's something
we see from time to time maybe not to
this extent
what does that say about
the way police handle situations like
this in america
americans today are celebrating the
fourth of july
and on this holiday season or weekend
we celebrate those who fought valiantly
but i'm afraid that law enforcement
fights against us
as police continue to sift through the
evidence left here at the scene where
jalen walker died there are many
questions the video doesn't answer
why did he evade the traffic stop in the
first place did he shoot at police why
leave the ring
why did police initially use tasers
which suggests they didn't think their
lives were in danger and finally what
changed to lead eight officers to fire
dozens of times into a man who as it
turned out was unarmed in the city of
akron now a fortress around the justice
center with barricades and trucks
blocking the roads police and city
leaders are hoping whatever the verdict
in the streets is it's very important
and everybody must vote
it will be a peaceful one john hendren
al jazeera akron ohio